um let's go next continuing our tour of
the united states via phone
let's go to the 850 area code caller
from 850
what's your name and where are you
calling from
hey david this is phillip and i'm coming
from mississippi i've got a florida
number though
thank you what's going on
well i've got two questions first of all
did you see the news recently where
trump actually admitted his game plan as
far as uh
the supreme court pick and kind of taken
going to
the supreme court and arguing against
the mailing ballot
and trying to um take over that way yep
absolutely so trump
trump has said he is counting on the
court system
to help him in november he says it's to
prevent it from being rigged
really it's too rigid and uh the federal
appeals courts could be a part of it
who knows depending on what happens the
supreme court could be a part of it
absolutely
right the second thing i wanted to
address is that um it seems though
the republicans the only way they can
get ahead is through through cheating at
least that
that's the kind of like what conclusion
i'm coming to i mean over the last seven
years as i'm sure you know
excuse me over the last seven elections
uh we've only had one republican
win by popular vote so this electoral
college and the gerrymandering
mandarin and all the judges that uh
recently mcconnell was picking it seems
the whole
game plan is to stay in power through
the with the republicans to stay in
power
just by trying to you know steal the
vote and oppress the vote
and if you look at you know you look at
polls and cnn and fox news and online
everybody leans left i mean all the
things that we want
all the things everybody is actually
voting for where voting is easy
is left-leaning policies but we don't
see that reflected in the white house
because the voting is just it's not
there that's not easy to vote so i
believe that
if we can never start having a
conversation about making
voting a national holiday about actually
doing like australia perhaps where they
have a fine if you don't vote or
or having the day off and just making it
easier more accessible i think we could
finally go in one direction in this
country instead of back and forth
ridiculous stuff every four to eight
years and actually get somewhere
yeah i think that's going to happen
unless we do something you know with the
supreme court which is kind of going to
be very difficult now at this point
well mandatory voting is kind of its own
question and i think that that's a
separate issue but you've beautifully
pointed out
that we have a system that you know we
talk
abstractly about checks and balances and
all of this stuff
but we have a system that in practice
allows
a center-left country to be uh
uh uh run by right-wing
uh legislative bodies and and judicial
bodies
because of the things you're pointing
out if you look at gerrymandering
you have a structural disadvantage for
democrats
when it comes to what percentage of the
vote do they need to get in order to
just have 50
representation you look at the senate
the senate
by giving two senators to each state
dramatically overstates the power of
these
states with very few people that still
get
to senators and i think it was something
like there were enough
you could have the senators representing
only 17 percent of the population
decide that trump is getting acquitted
in terms of impeachment because of that
imbalance and the fundamentally
undemocratic nature of the senate
you have the electoral college as you
point out wherein
you have a country that votes for
democrats many times
and many of those times a republican is
still elected president so you've
pointed out
many of the ways in which the country is
not really democratically run
and it is a major problem
right and i just don't feel like we're
going to make any consistent progress
forward no matter what we do in the next
four to eight years it could be undone
it's rents repeat we just keep going
back and forth and it's very difficult
to make consistent progress if we're not
able to lean in one direction
well i do think that if joe biden wins
and democrats take the senate you could
definitely undo
a bunch of the damage trump has done and
make some progress
but let's not put the cart before the
horse let's deal with november 1st and
then see where we are
right thanks for taking my call david
all right appreciate it thank you so
much
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you
don't have enough time to do all the
reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video